but first to the Muller probe the
special counsels investigation did not
find that the Trump campaign or anyone
associated with it conspired or
coordinated with Russia in its efforts
to influence the 2016 US presidential
election and quote that is Robert
mullahs conclusion after nearly two
years of investigating the matter the
Attorney General repeated versions of
that sentence four times in his summary
of Muller's report released yesterday
whatever you think of Donald Trump
it is now factually established that he
did not collude with Vladimir Putin to
steal the presidential election period
that case is now closed
this is the point in the story where
applause breaks out not just cheers from
Trump and his family and his campaign
staff and all those many people who are
told they were going to be indicted but
weren't but gratitude from the country
itself from all Americans of all
political parties for years we've all
been told that our government was being
controlled by a foreign power there were
spies in our midst the president United
States was one of them he was disloyal a
Quisling an agent of a nation that hates
us and seeks our destruction that man
was at the helm of our country
destroying democracy undermining our
values poisoning this nation from within
it was terrifying and millions of
Americans were terrified some wept as
they talked about their fear and
helplessness now we know that none of
that was true you would think the relief
at learning this would be overpowering
like finding out a terminal illness was
just a cold the long and bitter war has
ended we are safe but that is not how
most on the Left are responding tonight
they are not celebrating for their
country they are not grateful they are
angrier than ever to them the Muller
investigation has proved nothing and
exonerated no one Russian collusion is
as real to them as it was the day
Hillary Clinton first alleged it
progressives have not surrendered the
vast robot army of the Democratic Party
fights on as if nothing has changed the
fact that this investigation takes place
within the Justice Department which
Donald Trump essentially controls and
that he got rid of the problem Jeff
Sessions who
one decent thing that he did was just
recuse himself this guy is not recused
it feels like the seeds of a cover-up
are here Oh cover up and not just to
cover up but a cover-up
being perpetuated with the help of mr.
Robert S Mulliken trusted the one whose
report you look forward to like it was
Christmas the gray-haired angel of truth
who was going to deliver you from the
orange scourge our friends Robert Muller
it turns out Muller was part of this
conspiracy too it was a conspiracy so
brilliant so complex that he and 18
other federal prosecutors conducted a
two-year per Temkin investigation in
order to shield their plot from
discovery diabolical
why would Muller do that come on you
know the answer because it's always the
same answer
Robert Muller is a racist look if I'm
the trump children and I'm having I'm
having a party tonight right like they
won the white privilege vergata all
right like you cannot you cannot invest
it there is not an african-american
person in this country that could have
been investigated for 22 months have
their family investigated for 22 months
and come away scot free a racist plot
that's what NBC is telling you if that
sounds like a far-fetched claim keep in
mind that you're the wacko
they're always telling you that you're a
conspiracy nut they'll say you believe
in crazy things on the basis of zero
evidence you and Alex Jones you think
the left is coming for your guns you
think mass immigration is hurting this
country
you think illegal aliens are voting in
elections you imagine the tech companies
are censoring political speech you don't
trust the media and by the way you don't
believe in science and that's why you're
hesitant to give a 29 year old freshman
member of Congress complete control over
the US economy you're a lunatic you
should be ignored and so should Trump by
the way go ahead and ignore his
complaints about being persecuted
he's just whining here's NBC's
suggesting that it's actually Donald
Trump the guy who's been falsely
denounced for betraying his country as a
Russian agent who owes the apology an
apology to the prosecutors who hounded
him
did Robert Muller deserve better from
the president than this kind of language
and behavior he trashed him for two
years and in the end Muller just did an
investigation that ultimately the
president considers a total exoneration
of him did does he owe Robert Muller an
apology for that kind of rhetoric it
goes without saying that Democratic
members of Congress echoed these
sentiments or maybe was the other way
around the media aping the Democratic
Party suddenly it's hard to tell who's
taking cues from whom any remaining
distinctions between journalists and the
country's ruling class have long since
disappeared
reporters used to boast about holding
the powerful to account now they
scrambled to do their bidding The
Washington Post is owned by the richest
progressive in the world they're all one
interest group now you can't tell one
from another politicians and prosecutors
and Intel agency heads told us
implausible lies about Russian collusion
reporters are paid to push back but they
didn't instead they welcomed those lies
and then amplified them they were proud
to do that they're not apologizing for
it now in their first statement after
the Muller report summary became public
Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer the two
leaders of the Democratic Party in
Congress didn't mention the fact that
Trump had been cleared of collusion
neither did any Democratic politician
appearing on cable news Virginia
congressman Don Beyer insisted this
morning that quote there was a lot of
collusion within the Trump campaign even
though robert muller whom democrats have
told us many times is the final word on
the question had already told us
otherwise so nobody was fooled by any of
this well Larry's Muller's summary is on
the Internet you can read it yourself if
you want and reach your own conclusions
so by lying about the obvious and doing
it so obviously Democrats merely
revealed themselves to be everything
they claimed Donald Trump is stupid
irresponsible reckless corrupt
buffoonish they had to know their
talking points wouldn't work
they repeated them anyway why because
they didn't know what else to say
over on CNN and Jeff Zucker dispatched
his unit to address the channels
viewership meaning those Americans
trapped at the airport waiting for
flights you may think cNN has been lying
she relentlessly for the last two years
the eunuch explained not at all
cNN has done a fantastic job none of
this was our fault we're amazing listen
to him squeak reporting is what adds the
most value finding out something new
putting out new information into the
world is the best feeling in journalism
it's the greatest value add
that's what hundreds of journalists have
been doing trying to solve pieces of
this Trump rush a puzzle so don't be
fooled by the partisans who cherry-pick
the worst mistakes of individual
journalists or the craziest ideas from
commentators and claim that's the entire
media it's not we're waiting for the
facts because here is what I know I mean
you're gonna hear this from the right
for the next days and weeks to come that
the presses basically made all this up
to take down President Trump but the
press is just following a trail that
Trump created mm-hmm the greatest value
add
that's how CNN sums up its role in the
Russia story there's a single person
believe that of course not
not one person Jeff Zucker himself
doesn't believe that and that's why he
sent his marionette out to lies you just
saw Jeff Zucker is an anxious man
tonight he's been caught doing the one
thing journalists are not allowed to do
he intentionally misled his audience in
a fair world Jeff serger would be
running a car wash he'd be selling
timeshares in Cancun he would not be in
the news business so Kerr himself knows
that very well he knows he's an impostor
in a fair world CNN wouldn't call itself
a news network at all it's far less than
that and it has been for a long time
in 1996 CNN blamed the Olympic bombings
in Atlanta on an entirely innocent
innocent security guard named Richard
Jewell in the end CNN paid jewel a
settlement for slandering him but you'll
never recovered his life just two years
later CNN falsely accused the United
States military of murdering American
defectors during the Vietnam War with
sarin gas it was a ludicrous story based
on obvious lies CNN ran it anyway
because it confirmed their worldview
three years after that CNN implied again
on the basis of zero evidence that a
California Congressman Paul Gary Condit
had
one of his interns CNN's relentless
coverage helped drive Condit from office
Condit turned out to be innocent
too late his life and family were
destroyed now you'd think a news network
might learn from debacles like this and
yet under the leadership of Jeff Zucker
CNN's recklessness and his dishonesty
have only accelerated just this past
September CNN told us that Supreme Court
nominee Brett Kavanaugh was a serial
gang rapist alcoholic who targeted
underage girls then in January they told
us that a group of boys from a Catholic
school in Kentucky were dangerous bigots
who'd threatened a revered tribal elder
Vietnam veteran purely because they
hated American Indians every part of
that claim was a lie and CNN is now
facing a 275 million dollar lawsuit for
repeating that lie yet CNN kept going
just days after its Covington Catholic
fraud CNN decided to amplify yet another
racially divisive hoax Jessie small
that's manufactured hate crime and now
this exactly two weeks after Smollett
was indicted for telling the same lies
that see none uncritically repeated we
learned that the Russian collusion
narrative which by the way has formed
the backbone of CNN's entire programming
schedule for two years it's fake it's a
hoax
it never happened CNN responded by
congratulating itself Jeff Zucker still
runs the network his job apparently is
safe CNN's anchors wonderlad why
Americans don't trust the news media
must be that propaganda from Fox News
yep must be it has absolutely nothing to
do with coverage like this potentially
big new questions in the rush
investigation and the corresponding lack
of answers from the White House and any
kind of collusion with the Russians and
then there's the Russia investigation we
know the Russians were involved in
interfering with the election how do you
explain the Matta Ford allegations as
anything but collusion and it's on the
question of collusion possible collusion
with Russia fact it's Russia fact it's
Russia
okay thanks for that mr. Lamont so what
are these voices of authority you just
saw in CNN's
now that the facts have arrived have
they apologized or corrected themselves
or even acknowledged their role in
perpetuating this hoax hmm
let's see here's Carl Bernstein whose
sloppy Watergate reporting from half a
century ago somehow keeps him on
television to this day
Carly's thought a lot about this
question he's decided that in his August
and seasoned opinion as a celebrated
newsman CNN did a remarkable job here
and I think we've done the media the
press has done one of the great
reporting jobs in the history especially
of covering a presidency by the most
news organizations and look let's look
at where the disinformation and mistakes
and lying have come from hasn't come
from the press it's come from the
President of the United States and those
around him okay in case you're wondering
you may be why Donald Trump got elected
president of the United States you just
saw it Trump may be flawed but the
people in charge are just absurd the
Washington Post the New York Times have
no idea they still don't know why Trump
won the election they wholeheartedly
agree with their friend Carl Bernstein
both of those newspapers won Pulitzer
Prizes for their Russia's coverage in
its citation the poet's our committee
commended the reporters for their quote
deeply sourced relentlessly reported
coverage in the public interest that
dramatically furthered the nation's
understanding of Russian interference in
the 2016 presidential election and it's
connections to the Trump campaign the
president elects transition team and his
eventual administration end quote need
that run-on sentence again if you dare
you might want to keep those words
somewhere as a keepsake momento like
that Dewey defeats Truman headline from
the Chicago Tribune so many years ago a
monument to human absurdity your
grandkids can read it and snicker The
Times in the post so don't get the joke
they have no plans to return their
prizes they think they did a great job
the rest of us can keep laughing but
there's an ominous lesson here too
our leaders are not fit to lead they
have no idea what they're doing and they
won't admit it they're hysterical
children
and stupid and vain they care only about
themselves they learn nothing from their
mistakes and so their self regard
undiminished they march on to the next
disaster full of self-righteous
confidence the next battle they tell us
is over obstruction of justice it
doesn't seem to occur to them that
justice is precise precisely what we got
yesterday 19 federal prosecutors spent
nearly two years investigating the
Democratic Party's claim that Donald
Trump stole the presidential election
investigators in the case had a
limitless budget and essentially no
restrictions of any kind they hired
dozens of FBI agents intelligence
analysts and forensic accountants to
help them investigate the issued nearly
three thousand subpoenas they received
hundreds of search warrants and hundreds
more surveillance orders they showed up
at people's homes with automatic weapons
pointed in their faces they spied on
American citizens they read their texts
downloaded their emails they interviewed
at least 500 separate witnesses not
since September 11th have federal
investigators dug more deeply into a
case and in the end they proved the
charges false Democrats have decided to
ignore the findings instead they say
they want justice by which of course
they mean revenge punishment power
that's what they've always wanted the
rest of this the Muller investigation
included was staged purely for show
shame on the rest of us were falling for
it yet again you'd like to believe the
people who did this will be held
accountable they hurt our country they
poisoned our public sphere they
distorted our foreign policy they
completely terrified the population they
should be punished it's not like we
don't punish people here we live in a
society where people lose their jobs for
believing in biology a place where
college students risk having their lives
destroyed for telling the wrong joke
America is suddenly a very punitive
place but these people will escape what
they deserve you know they will because
they so often have before the very same
people who push the rush of collusion
conspiracy are the ones who told us
Saddam Hussein had weapons of mass
destruction in 2003 of here's after that
they discern us that the housing market
was absolutely solid no problem go ahead
and invest just the other day they
informed us that we'll have to
stay in Syria and Afghanistan forever
because of threats that only they
understand tomorrow they'll be telling
you to take the bus to work because of
global warming they will never take the
bus they won't have to they will never
face the consequences of the disasters
they created instead they'll keep
getting rich from failure another TV
contract another committee chairmanship
another fat grant from a Soros funded
foundation and as they prosper they will
continue to lecture you from Twitter
about your imaginary moral failings
shut up racist obey that's what's likely
to happen in the aftermath of this hos
that's what's always happened how long
do they think this can continue